hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
the first two days of the democratic
national convention offering up
big names and a few surprises but will
it be enough
to unite the party and win over those
coveted independents
fox news radio's national correspondent
jared halpern
and fox news radio's political analyst
josh crushauer break down the biggest
moments
and look ahead to this evening and the
u.s postal service will play a
central role in the presidential
election process as a record number of
americans are expected to vote
by mail but amid a pandemic and concerns
over the potential for fraud
and delivery delays are states ready
minnesota secretary of state steve simon
and ohio secretary of state frank larose
discuss how they plan to ensure
any ballot mailed is counted plus
commentary from paul batura
author and the vice president of
communications for the global christian
ministry
focus on the family the fox news rundown
is a daily news podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe
on your favorite podcast player by going
to foxnewspodcasts.com
i'm ainsly earhart i'm charles payne i'm
martha mccallum and this
is the fox news rundown
wednesday august 19 2020
i'm jared halpern democrats officially
nominate
joe biden to be their candidate to take
on president trump
in november it's either going to be a
really close race
that either one could win which gets
decided in that in those midwestern
states
or it's a big biden victory which gets
decided in the south
i'm jessica rosenthal concerns about the
post office
may be bipartisan for those running our
elections
the postal service is moving slow
that's concerning as are some of the
reasons behind the slowdown
it was ill-timed and particularly at a
time when
nationwide there's a growing appetite
for voting from home
and using the males it was ill-timed and
i'm paul batura
i've got the final word on the fox news
rundown
[Music]
the main agenda item at any party's
political convention is to nominate a
candidate for president
that was done at the democratic national
convention tuesday night
a roll call vote state by state
territory by territory casting their
votes
culminating in the official nomination
of joe biden
vice president joe biden has officially
been nominated
by the democratic party as our candidate
for president
of the united states of course in the
modern era with little drama about
who will claim the nomination political
conventions serve as a four-day
infomercial an ad for the party for the
ticket
arnon mishkin is the director of the fox
news decision desk
he joined me and fox news radio
political analyst josh cross
our to chat about the idea of the
message who democrats are trying to sell
to
to turn their fortunes around from four
years ago
having watched the first two nights of
the convention i would say that the two
groups they're trying to target the most
are number one minorities and number two
young people
and it was a bit surprising to me for
the first night and then i realized no
if you look at the polling
there is some evidence of some weakness
and or weakness and enthusiasm amongst
minority groups
even though i think biden is getting the
bulk of them but the question is
to what extent will they turn out to
vote particularly this year
given kovid given the questions about
mail in battle
and the like and the second group which
is actually
is very lukewarm to biden and you see it
in the polling is
young people and i think they've done a
number in a number of the
different segments where they have
clearly in terms of
the the people they featured the kind of
music they played
to basically try to reach those
millennials or gen z
um who are voting for the first of the
second time
um so i think that's those are the two
groups that they they were targeting in
their ads
i think there have been two core
messages that the
uh convention has been trying to send
the first message
is donald trump is a bad president he is
responsible for kobit
he's responsible for every bad thing
that's going on um
and i think that's uh the appropriate
message in an election which i think is
very much a referendum on donald trump
and the second message that that comes
through
is joe biden is a really nice guy the
other thing that and you talk about sort
of this idea that you know they're
trying to sell joe biden as a very
likable guy that came across
in the video presentation uh narrated by
cindy mccain the widow
of the late senator john mccain
obviously a republican the the 2008
republican nominee for president
she stopped short of endorsing joe biden
but does that kind of message hearing
from
from those types of figures in the
republican establishment
move the needle at all for perhaps
republican voters who may from maybe a
foreign policy or style or substance
just not be
all the way there with president trump i
think they're clearly trying to do that
there was a thing is it a small universe
of people
yeah i think it's i think it is really
is a small universe of people
but there is a universe in the middle
that sort of independent leaning
uh republican-leaning independents that
do find that appealing and then there's
a large universe in the middle
that likes bipartisanship bipartisanship
doesn't sell in primaries
but in general elections there's
probably two or three percent
that kind of really likes bipartisanship
i think it was one of the reasons
uh mitt romney looked like he was had a
potential advantage over
president obama in 2012 was because he
was able to say
had a real track record of
bipartisanship and even though obama had
a
great rhetoric about bipartisanship the
track record of his first term
did not suggest a lot of bipartisanship
hey arnold
we didn't hear a lot about uh the
running mate senator
kamala harris we will hear her tomorrow
night i'm sure there's going to be a
much
uh renewed focus in the next two days
but
any evidence on where she helps the the
biden ticket and
what what she does for the for the for
the nominee
i think that you know heading into this
thing there was a sense that
that she was there was a question of
whether or not she would help with the
african-american vote
and it's it isn't totally clear i think
the jury is still out
she was clearly not one of the the
people who were being considered
vice president who had really solid
support amongst the african-american
community
but nonetheless she has made a lot of
outreach to that group and she may be
effective there
i think the most important thing from
the biden perspective about the kamala
harris
decision was that she's fine
and that she was and that she was it was
not a big surprise
everyone sort of had thought she was the
natural person for the ticket
um when she first ran they thought she
was really running for vice president
and and so i think that that sort of
underscored the idea that
i'm joe biden and it will be a normal
four years
there won't be anything really
surprising it'll be fine
um so i think from that perspective it
may have helped you know
the polling is there's still no really
good polling because you have to wait
for it to settle for a few days to
really be able to pull this
but the initial sign suggested that the
public was fine with it and she has
so far not made a a a big gap
where is this race over the next uh
three months going to be decided
you talk sort of about the the
persuadables and
how small or large that population may
be
is there a region where where this race
ultimately is decided that that sort of
speaks to
to to those demographics that that are
still persuadable in this race
i i think that where the race is going
to be decided
is i mean who is the next president it
gets decided in the upper midwest
um you know the traditional battleground
states
or swing states of pennsylvania michigan
and wisconsin maybe ohio maybe
iowa possibly i think that's where the
race gets decided
the big question mark about this race
because
right now i think you have a choice it's
either going to be a really close race
that either one could win which gets
decided in that in those midwestern
states
or it's a big biden victory which gets
decided in the south
meaning florida georgia north carolina
and texas
i don't think biden's going to carry all
of those states
he may even carry none of those states
but i think the biden strategy is sort
of
let's make sure we win the upper part of
the country the
the the big swing states and let's make
sure
that trump people are spending a lot of
time and a lot of money in texas and
florida
north carolina and georgia which will
decide if it's a landslide or a small
or a very close election what states we
talk about the the midwestern states you
just went over the
the political and demographic math there
but
it does feel like there's a new wave of
traditionally republican
states that could be in play this
november i think arizona
georgia maybe even texas do you think
biden what is sort of the upper limit of
how joe biden
could stretch the map if everything goes
his way
oh if everything goes his way it's it
would be a very significant victory i
mean i think
he is within striking distance in
florida georgia north carolina texas
definitely arizona um and
i don't see other sort of traditionally
republican states where he could
where he isn't seriously within striking
distance
and even in those states i think a lot
of them are what i call
democratic fools gold um historically
democratic fools gold they'll think
they're gonna they could win they'll
spend a lot of money there
and that's gonna be a waste of money in
this particular case
i suspect what they do there won't be a
waste of money because
the polling suggests that even though
trump might win them
he's going to have to really fight to
win and and it is a zero-sum game
if if you're fighting in one state
you're not able to fight another
and so that becomes that could be a a
major problem for the president
we'll finish uh the conversation with
this over the next
two nights now arnin what do you think
the democratic message needs to do what
still needs to be accomplished for the
democrats to try and
and change their fortunes from four
years ago i think they need to hone
hammer away at the two messages they're
trying to hammer away which is
donald trump is responsible for the
problems today both the economy
and the um covid thing and then the
second thing is
joe biden is a good guy and
to inoculate himself against some of the
questions about age
um some of that has been inoculated uh
but the sort of the question of why
doesn't he do more live media interviews
why isn't he on fox news sunday for
instance
um some of those questions and sort of
anything that indicates that he still is
up to the game
i think is is is obviously very
important
uh for the democrats this time around
and then the second thing that they need
to do
is to to inoculate themselves against an
attack that
even if joe biden wins you want to make
sure you have a republican senate to
check
the president um and which you know it's
another message that could appeal to one
or two percent of the public
and so anything to sort of fight that i
think is something that the democrats
ought to try to make sure they do
we will see uh how that plays out arnon
mishkin is the director of the fox
news decision desk as always we
appreciate your time the third night of
the democratic national convention this
evening california senator kamala harris
will claim her party's nomination
for vice president our coverage will
kick off at eight o'clock eastern
on fox news radio stations across the
country in the fox news app
[Music]
this is paul patero with your fox news
commentary coming up
the postmaster general is supposed to
testify before a senate committee friday
and a house committee monday
after concerns about the postal service
got wrapped up in concerns over voting
mostly because many of us may end up
voting by mail due to concerns over the
virus
president trump has said he has concerns
that universal mail-in voting could lead
to fraud
as some states like nevada are sending
all registered voters ballots
whether they requested one or not he
said regardless the post office wouldn't
be able to handle it all
the post office has been a disaster for
many many decades
we want to strengthen the post office
make it good it lost
78 billion dollars over a relatively
short number of years
78 billion i want to strengthen the post
office
and we can do it attention then turned
to the post office and the postmaster
general lewis dejoy's restructuring
efforts which included the reduction of
mailboxes and sorting machines
and a reduction in some office hours and
overtime
some democrats like new york senator
chuck schumer have cried foul to slow
down the mail at any time is disgraceful
to slow it down at covid is despicable
and hurts people's lives others have
accused dejoy who was a big republican
donor and donated to the president's
2016 campaign
of purposely slowing down things at the
post office to help the president make a
point about mail-in voting
others say the postal service is losing
money and lost nearly
nine billion dollars in the last fiscal
year alone
so some restructuring may be called for
mark diminsteen is the president of the
american postal workers union
and he doesn't agree with that postal
service has a burden from 2006 that
nobody else has in the public or private
sector
of pre-funding retiring health health
care costs 75 years into the future
that's for people that weren't even born
yet so a lot of these are paper losses
if you take out that pre-funding mandate
actually the post office made money in
most in
in most of those years democrats have
argued the postal service needs more
funding
and that states need more money for
mail-in ballots de joy is scheduled to
appear before congressional committees
friday
and next monday and yesterday he
announced restructuring changes like
mailbox and mail sorting machine removal
are now on hold i think it's a move in
the right direction i think it's welcome
news
steve simon is minnesota's democratic
secretary of state we always knew
that voting from home by absentee was a
safe and secure way of voting
and now we know that the postal service
won't stand in the way and
could ultimately be helpful in that
process now before
mr dejoy issued his statement tuesday
the usps had sent most states including
yours letter saying that due to
state rules they may not be able to get
all the the mailed in votes to elections
officials in time to be counted on
election day
i think you you said you weren't that
worried right because a judge in your
state has ruled that
as long as the ballot was postmarked by
election day it would count up to one
week after the election
yeah that's right and the letter left
that part out which is why i'm not sure
what the purpose of the letter
really was but in the end we have a
standing court ruling for this year and
this year only
very on brand for 2020 that says that
that
in minnesota the normal rule will be
altered and the rule this year for
november will be that
all ballots postmarked as late as
election day will be accepted
if they come in in the next seven days
so if you mail it on tuesday november
third election day
as long as it gets in by tuesday
november 10th you're good to go if it
gets in the next day
that's a spoiled ballot so but that must
mean there are some real concerns that
we we won't have results on election
night right because
so many more people have expressed an
interest in voting by mail
well what it means is we won't have
final results on election night by
definition in minnesota it won't be
until seven days later that we have all
the results but i strongly suspect we'll
know the vast majority of
outcomes on election night and the
reason for that is
we'll be announcing as soon as we can
either on election night or very shortly
thereafter
how many outstanding absentee ballots
there are
per legislative district that's our goal
anyway
so that if candidate a is ahead of
candidate b by a thousand votes let's
say on election night
but you know very close in time to
election night that there are only 700
outstanding absentee ballots you could
probably call that race for candidate a
because even if all the absentee ballots
that were outstanding went for the other
candidate
it wouldn't impact the results so we
think the outcomes will be known
the vast majority of them will be just
not the margin and the final vote totals
now let's get back to the post office
for a second um you are quoted as saying
that
of postmaster general lewis dejoy's
restructuring changes which
on tuesday he said are on hold um that
the effects of those
seem suspicious and i wanted to follow
up with you about what you mean
did you do you think the postal service
was you know trying to manufacture
a delay or or even like you know god
forbid like a malfunction
in the election well not so much a
malfunction but um
but i think there's certainly
circumstantial evidence that a lot of
the decisions
that were made at the top had the effect
i'll lead to others to say whether it
was the intended effect but certainly
had the effect according to a lot of the
reporting
of slowing down the mail things like
stopping over time things like
uh you know making decisions about the
distribution of sorting equipment that
said
as you have just said that that decision
or those decisions are on hold so i want
to give credit where it's due
if that report is accurate but yeah
that's what i meant it
it was ill-timed and particularly at a
time when
nationwide there's a growing appetite
for voting from home
and using the males it was ill-timed
now but let me follow up with you on
that because the postal service has said
um that they could run out of money by
september because of kovid
and we know pre in you know in previous
years um before
the president was even before trump was
president um
there have been removals of mailboxes
before it's all based on you know demand
and certainly the advent of email has
changed that
um and we know from from last year that
the postal service had an
almost a nine billion dollar shortfall
um is some general restructuring of the
post
post office in order given these numbers
yeah i have to assume there are changes
that need to be made and it's not for me
to say
what in particular they might be i do
know that there's been some dispute
about what the real
losses are the post office unlike other
federal agencies at least according to
the reporting
is it has to report on its book certain
retirement expenses that no one else
does
and then there's a general aspect too
that the postal service is a service
it's not a profit making business it's
sort of like saying well the fire
department in my town loses money hand
over fist because it takes in zero at a
fair box there isn't one
and cost millions of dollars every year
does the fire department lose money
i guess that's way one way of looking at
it but the postal service yeah takes in
so much in stamps and
other collections and costs way more
than that to run is that a loss or is it
like saying the fire department has
suffered a loss it's a philosophical
debate
but there's no doubt in my mind like any
organization it could always stand some
reform
and i hope that happens in a way that
just isn't disruptive
before an election simon says there's a
tremendous interest in voting by mail in
this election in minnesota
and voters who want to vote by mail will
not be sent a ballot automatically in
his state
they must identify themselves and
request a ballot be sent
this is a system the president has said
he is comfortable with and it's the same
system for voters in ohio
who also want to vote by mail where
frank larose is the republican secretary
of state
he says he's taking some action to
prepare for any concerns
with the postal system with our vote by
mail system you know
we're working to spread the word so that
ohioans know that yeah things may be
running slower than usual right now with
the postal service so get your xt ballot
in right away don't delay on that and
i'm actually working right now to try to
convince our state legislature to offer
me
the ability and i need their permission
to do it but i can use
three million dollars out of my own
budget to offer postage paid so that
every one of those pallets
has a postage paint envelope so uh
really uh
there's no good excuse for not mailing
it in so
talk to me about the postal service for
a second because they sent out letters
to
pretty much of almost every state saying
you know
look your situation means uh ballots are
probably not going to be
all counted by election day what is your
system do ballots get counted if they
come in
you know as long as they're postmarked
by election day and you know
it's like a week-long grace period what
what's your situation
so in ohio we actually have 10 days and
as long as it's postmarked by
monday and that as you mentioned every
state's different but in ohio it's got
to be postmarked by monday november 2nd
and it can arrive at that board of
elections up to 10 days later now one
thing to point out there is we always
tell people that election night results
are unofficial
well this year it may be more unofficial
than usual right because we know that
we're going to see a high high number of
absentee ballots
cast and that's a good thing we want
ohioans to do that
but that means that ballots could
continue to arrive on wednesday thursday
friday for 10 days after the election
and so when the results change between
election night
and then a few weeks later when the
official total comes out
that doesn't mean that something
nefarious is happening in fact that that
is
the very manifestation of our commitment
that every vote counts every voice
matters and so those legally cast fc
ballots will be
will be counted uh days after but you're
right to mention you know the postal
service
is moving slow uh that's concerning uh
as a
member of the national association of
secretaries of state we've been
uh asking for a meeting with the
postmaster general and and
my message when hopefully i have the
chance to talk to the postmaster general
is this
process improvements and efficiency
improvements are great i'm sure that
there
are things that need to be improved
about the way the postal service
operates
but to the extent that those are
disruptive
we just can't be doing that between now
and election day those are great changes
to make maybe in december
when we're past this election but what
we can't have
is uh you know the post office trying
new ways of doing business with that
having a detrimental impact on elections
that's just not acceptable
and the postmaster general actually just
released a statement saying just that
they are not going to be removing
election
or they're not going to be removing
mailboxes they're not going to be taking
out male sorting machines they're
expanding their leadership team on
handling ballots for the election so it
sounds like um
sounds like he's heard folks like you
well that's important and i'm glad to
hear that uh
the postal service is essential to
elections administration it's part of
a big part of the way we run elections
as i said in a just a normal election
and nothing's normal in any of our lives
right now
up to a quarter of ohioans that vote are
going to vote absentee
in just a normal election so one out of
four voters can expect to mail their
ballot in
that number is going to go higher this
year i think it could be as much as
twice as high
and i want to for ohioans that have this
first experience voting absentee
i want it to become a lifelong habit for
them so i want to make sure that it's a
smooth
experience for them and they can by the
way one of the things that ohio would
need to know is that you can track your
ballot by going to voteohio.gov
it's just like tracking a package you
order online and so you can rest assured
that your vote was counted by
that it was received by the board of
elections frank larose thank you so much
for your time
hey thank you really appreciate it take
care jessica
fox news radio on demand on the fox news
app download the app and just click
listen when you swipe left you can
listen to your favorite fox news talk
shows
live swipe right for the latest fox news
radio newscasts on demand
fox news radio and the fox news app
download it today
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
it's time for your fox news commentary
paul patera
what's on your mind the united states
post office is in the news these days
and according to some
president trump wants to cut their
funding in order to orchestrate a
diabolical election-year plot
in order to ensure his re-election i
wonder if vladimir putin is somehow
behind all of this
based on this wild theory mail delivery
will be so slow by november that ballots
processed through the postal service
won't arrive in time to be counted for
the 2020 presidential election
i guess the thought is that more
democrats will vote by mail than
republicans
though it's not clear to me how the post
office will know which ballots are for
mr biden
and which ones are from mr trump
conspiracy theories always break down
somewhere
president obama actually accused mr
trump of trying to actively kneecap an
agency whose roots go back to 1775
and the second continental congress
please mr president look and see
you wouldn't really do that to me would
you when it comes to our opinion of the
post office i'm reminded a bit of our
typical reaction to congress
if asked the vast majority of americans
disapprove of congress
but most of those same people will vote
to re-elect their representative
we don't like congress but we like our
congressman or congresswoman
in the same way i think most of us agree
the post office is a massive
poorly run bureaucratic bungle it lost
almost 9 billion
last year its 13th consecutive year of
being in the red
but i sure like our mailman here in
colorado springs
his name is will and he's a jovial
upbeat and friendly guy
who goes out of his way to be helpful he
even gives our kids candy every now and
again
president trump isn't trying to sabotage
the post office he's concerned about
voter fraud
and wants to make sure the ballots are
secure and every legal vote
counted with over six hundred thousand
employees i'm sure there are some bad
actors within the post office
but the same could be said about any
business or organization
yes the postal service may lose a lot of
money but they know how to deliver mail
they handled a hundred and forty two and
a half billion pieces last year
that's a lot of packages letters
postcards and ballots
it's been almost 60 years since the
marvalettes wrote hey mr postman to the
top of the billboard
charts but their verse seems to now be
the latest
liberal vice and conspiracy theory
you'll remember the motown hit ends with
this pithy lament
so many days you passed me by see the
tears standing in my
eye you didn't stop to make me feel
better
by leaving me a card or a letter i think
we'll feel better when we get through
the rest of 2020
when the election is over and the
coronavirus has finally abated
by the way i think it's pretty amazing
that for just 55 cents
55 cents the post office will deliver a
letter
thousands of miles for me but shh please
don't say anything
i think maybe that's why they're losing
so much money i'm paul batura
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network
subscribe and listen to the trey gowdy
podcast
former federal prosecutor and four-term
u.s congressman from south carolina
brings you a one-of-a-kind podcast
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes